bon alors andré bercoff tu publies chez
albin michel 4
comment aider mitterrand a sauvé le
capitalisme en france et chez laffont la
france des seigneurs tu sais ce que ça
fait valoir sa bleue vous et vous voilà
une interview vous tout est prêt
m
bon alors une armée ou quatre ans
aujourd'hui est bien quand on récidive
wes qu'il a estimé que mitterrand n'est
pas en train d'aider le capitalisme en
france comme il l'a fait pendant six ans
ouais
pendant six ans à une bourse génial
ouais les golden boys super on a eu des
tapis gagnant est en ce moment on est
des infirmiers protection des agents de
maîtrise de la technique giggle d'easy
lutteurs qui veulent se prendre pour
plus gros constructeur ça va pas du tout
parce que si le peuple commence à
gueuler pour l'ami la gauche couloirs
alors 80 cats ont alors été remis à leur
conseil me libérant savoir comment la
caste supérieure doit gérer ce pays
c'est je donne des conseils très précis
et très détaillés change pas gâteau
c'est toujours le discours des maîtres
la langue des mains de la langue des
maîtres
ce qui vaut à la seule qui vaut mais
pour expliquer au peuple comment
raisonne les maîtres cette amante en la
libérant comment il l'a entamé son
second septennat fait tout est parfait
parfait parfait parce qu'il a été comme
bouddha on a compris ce qu'était le
bouddhisme zen il a dit je suis là c'est
ce que fait des heures sup délit cible
bigoudis paternellement qu'est-ce qui
fait rien il est là il faut bien savoir
qu'il n'a pas gagné parce qu'il avait un
programme
il a gagné parce qu'il n'avait rien à
dire aujourd'hui c'est important de
n'avoir rien à dire sur le reste de
pouvoir
plus tu es absolument un zombie muet
plus qui peut rester au pouvoir
c'est très important et littéraire a
compris ça admirablement c'est à dire
que plus ça va aller puisqu'il va rester
immobile et dix ans je suis le gardien
des références telles références on n'en
sait rien ça n'a aucune importance je
suis larbitre des vrais conflits quel
conflit on en sait rien ça n'a aucune
importance je suis là et je décrète ceux
qui la morale le bien et le mal le vrai
et le faux mais ne posez pas la question
savoir qui est le bien qui est le mal
qui nous relevons ça n'a aucune
importance
sachez qu'il y ait un arbitre qui le dit
max théret a mad max formidable mad max
bad max tu comprends il est sur son lit
d'hôpital il attend mais on oublie que
ce type a dépensé des millions pour
aider les journaux de gauche qui appelle
les nouvelles littéraires
le matin c'est lui alors qu'on lui
espère un solde de tout compte
je veux dire qu'est ce que c'est c'est
lamentable si on va plus rattraper un
ravin qui passaient la caisse a presque
complètement
je trouve qu'ils ont été il faut laisser
match se relaxer il a été très bien il a
mérité de la place vanak
absolument bon alors regard à aucun
formidable rocard est l'exemple même de
saint sébastien c'est juste du jeune
justin ou les infortunes de la vertu
en 1981 il dit je me présente à la
présidence tous derrière mitterrand
mitterrand qu'est ce qui lui fait le
coup du lapin il apparu qu'il avait une
laisse qu'il avait intégré un avis le
tir 87,10 recommence il lui dit je me
présente et je serai candidat croit
qu'il arrive que fait mr hyde est rien
il vient me voir cette fois ci cette
fois ci l'a reçue de l'égout tu fais pas
le con tu seras premier ministre est un
bon premier
ils l'ont eue communiste et rocard a su
mais non ces canards fatwa qui connaît
les arcanes du monde politique quand un
mec tu dis ferme-la tu seras premier
ministre quelle preuve en avait que pour
écrire un papier quand même comment ça
se passe faut faire confiance quand même
mais on peut faire confiance la preuve à
bord la preuve il s'est dit je vais un
peu dans ce milieu là c'est un peu comme
quand il ya une parole quoi ces écoutes
quand al capone va marie sigal c'est ce
que je voulais dire et lui dit
on va se partager le territoire fait pas
chier pour le moment j'ai mon territoire
du nord aucune chance tu es mort qui tue
franchise le territoire tu sais je vais
pas rester longtemps
je suis là j'ai encore pour quelques
années alors m'emmerde pas et c'était
bon si tu assumes si tu montres que tu
vas me le droit chemin
tu as des changes il vient tu as des
chances alors on en arrive à la france
des seniors mauroy c'est un des seniors
parce que finalement les seniors c'est
quoi ces 100 mecs quoi
quitterie comme des seigneurs pour le
bicentenaire de la révolution toi tu les
cours que finalement il ya 100 mecs qui
tiennent le bled pensait absolument ils
ont leur fief
ouais ils ont été ou parachuté au miso
tes fils leur père comme baudis ou
médecins où ils ont été élus tous ces
gens lecanu est la première fois qu il a
fait de la politique car ou en droit
sont pas le 10 mai sa part jean tu veux
faire la politique nous sommes une
famille honnête nous l'a compris depuis
non mais c'est vrai qu'il y a une
relation de proximité entre les français
et leur mère ou leur président du
conseil général c'est le nouvel or
féodal quoi comme s'explique alors ta
midi journalistes sur le coton fait
l'espèce d'état des lieux
voilà et ce bouquin va être mis à jour
les ans a régulièrement là donc on sera
quand on veut monter une affaire en
province on sera qu'il faut s'adresser
sécu simplement absurde on leur donne
les fiefs les modalités tu à chaban
médecin me roy ils sont là ils bougeront
pas faudra les tuer
il bougeait et puis et puis les uns des
âmes bien parce que gèrent bien leur
faut pas oublier j'ai bien envie là
c'est pas des tocards c'est pas des
ringards tu restes par 40 ans dans une
ville à étendre un gars et des bons
tapis maintenant parce que tu sais quand
même quand accuse d'être le [ __ ] de
tapis tapie n'a pas besoin de neige
ouais moi j'ai travaillé sur le bouquin
de tapis moi j'aime bien tapie je
défends je sais qu'on l'attaquent
beaucoup en ce moment mais tu sais tu
appuies m'amuse parce que c'est un bon
voyons les maroc et il sait et puis
c'est comme le sol quand vous affrontez
l'open directement à jean edern hallier
qui a affronté marchands et leurs alliés
justement tu as vu quand même que
l'idiot international a été distribué à
350 milles exemplaires dans tous les
kiosques de france et de navarre
vas y tu as vu ce qu'ils racontaient
dedans il ya deux solutions soit c'est
faux et est-ce qu'on lie à aucune raison
que ce soit avec les nems pp le
diffusant toute la france soit c'est
vrai c'est quand même bizarre qui aucun
journaliste c'est vrai qu'ils s'en
soient préoccupés désaccord avec moi à
mon avis ça mérite tout à fait une
enquête et je m'étonne que les
journalistes sérieux dont le phocéen ce
qui est quand même là tant que tapie lui
a mis un flingue dans la bouche en lui
lisant fous moi la paix moi je suis
manipulé
c'est francis le belge c'est l'argent de
francis le belge qui finance le pn tu
l'as lu tout ça lance au liban
non je suis très étonné que ça lui
aucune espèce de réaction c'est quand
même ville
je veux dire personne n'a parlé personne
n'a rien dit on est content on s'amuse
on dira c'est rigolo et d'un allié pour
la merde
tapie c'est bien parce que c'est bien de
le flaguais mais ça n'a rien fait moi je
joue ça amusant mais c'est vrai que si
j'étais rédacteur en chef du journal je
ferai une vraie enquête pour savoir ce
que c'est moi j'ai passé le reste c'est
pas vrai le tout ça s'appelle le prouver
savoir qu'elle fait une vraie enquête
par séguéla à séguéla gelant bien parce
que celle et là tu comprends c'est la
société du spectacle dans son ample et a
passé sa vie à le dire peu implication
faisait de la pierre pesait plus que la
cogip changer le monde
la pub à l'échangé le que jésus qui
avait inventé la plongée du bien vivante
et la pub en dix ans la masse à bach
thani qui étais tu sais que le premier
homme s'était adam ouais enfin bon
et puis tout lac où il découvrit bien
mais y'a pas que l'argent est le coeur
ouais en vue d'amortir la cantine
pugnace et le coup de corne à grand
chose maintenant qu'on a fait en tulle
ont pour eux de venir gauche et oui ça
va marcher le problème c'est quand on
rencontre des coeurs de placer plus haut
mais enfin on aime bien ces
questionnaires solaire j'aime beaucoup
parce que sollers il a compris un truc
tu sais les [ __ ] africains on les
appelle les boutiques beaucoup et cela
se faisait des bouquins qui marchait pas
du tout et puis un jeu il s'est dit je
veux faire bouddhique mon pure
littérature et du coup ça marche du
tonnerre de dieu à une ombre alors on va
rire en vendée quand il faisait h au
paradis milliards dans des verrines
maintenant elle en vend 200 milles 1 tu
rigoles achever un divan des deux sens
ouais enfin 200 milles mais c'est bien
mais il a je vais dire il a compris va
les faire du cul et de la culture
c'est à dire qu'il fait lui mais surtout
300 pages justement tu as été rédacteur
en chef de lui absolument un an
tu penses quoi qu'ils vivent et qui
écoute filipacchi il m'amuse parce que
cet individu
jour écouter les journalistes n existe
pas il ya les photos et entre le gris ça
se passe au m pour lui il aimait les
mots c'est du crime tu vois les photos
voilà il ya en fait la visualisation
esquive mais moi je vais délire c'est un
type honnête parce qu'il a été prêtre
enfin avec moi en tout cas ils avaient
tous deux été exemplaire avec l'atelier
des bonnes indemnités même pas même pas
même pas mais je vais te dire j'ai bien
vécu
oui je me suis bien amusé pendant un an
au bout donnant je ne pouvais rien faire
alors ah bon tu peux rien faire tu leur
as honte et huawei alors on reste dans
le groupe matra hachette bernard henri
lévy mais alors il avis la nouvelle vie
aux offices tu m'as dit assez bien la
nouvelle philosophie le problème c'est
que tout ça c'est fini je veux dire ça
n'existe plus ça a été ma en cinq ans
parce que tu vois les gens avaient
oublié que ce l'air avait oublié david
rousset a eu tous ces gens là alors on
leur dit attention les gars et à le
goulag
et puis arrive seule chine ici alors on
dit c'est formidable et le goulag c'est
bien même c'est qu'il ya eu 40 ans avant
des gens qui l'avaient dit mais tu sais
c'est toujours pareil il y en avait un
type qui avait envoyé sa main entre deux
morceaux de foie
alors moi j'ai suggéré mme henri lévy
d'écrire un bouquin eu deux avis que ça
permet les choses de lévis alors le
dernier nom de man who is who berk berk
of le chuchoteur de perversité et son
aspect coraux comme beaucoup pratiquent
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus